hey what's up party people welcome to
another
live episode of australia commentaries
we are back baby we just recorded one
before this it's gonna be out this
afternoon
but right now we're talking about thor
four i think yes
great
great thor 411 thunder uh we'll be
watching the trailer together we'll be
watching some deleted scenes we'll be
answering questions and comments from
viewers like yourselves keep those
coming in the chat and ryan will pop
them into the script here and then uh
we'll leave you with a clue for next
week's on his trailer
just as fun as thor ford
all right uh this movie um look uh
i think we're pretty negative about this
movie i think this was one of the more
negative honest trailers we've done in
recent memory and i only do that out of
love and thunder because uh ragnarok was
my favorite mcu movie up certainly top
tier for me in the in the upper echelon
of the mcu
and i think that raised my expectations
yeah uh to an unfair degree i think i
was expecting a a balance that that
lived on the razor's edge of comedy and
drama and and uh fun and uh
but still with character and this just
fell apart man this just fell apart for
me real fast and stayed that way i just
look i
after like the fourth goat thing oh god
like the go go like there's too too many
goats and way too much korg like korg is
like a sp and i know we joke that folks
don't know how to use seasoning but like
you can't just lick salt you know what i
mean and it just is you're at the salt
lick you're at the salt lake with cork
and it's i i do because i think that
that is a great character when used like
minimally and it almost felt like it was
at the sacrifice of a better character
which is valkyrie who could have had
more to do than as i've said uh bring
hateration and holleration in this
dancery i'm very glad that she did so
but
she probably could have done more than
just be like here are my weapons and
here's my like beat spider yeah yeah
here's my there was a speaker it was
overstuffed um
in a you know in a plot and character i
feel like joke wise there were just too
many jokes that didn't land
there's a lot of marvel tropes and
things that mcu movies do that i think
we we kind of complain about here
intermixed with things we like like it's
and and this movie i feel like was very
tilted on it's a lot of the stuff i'm
tired of them doing without a lot of the
stuff that i like so the the constant
jokey jokiness so you can't take
anything seriously and it doesn't feel
like there's stakes the visuals where
it's a lot of like all your main
characters bunched into the foreground
in front of like elaborately animated
sets and backdrops and it's just like a
lot of these different instincts all
collected into one movie that made it
kind of irritating whereas if we weren't
20 some films into this franchise i feel
like it would have felt it might be
refreshing yeah yeah and like i don't
need
every marvel movie like i understand
that this is kind of like a rebuilding
phase i don't need every marvel movie to
be like hey like we're teasing towards
the big thing that's happening
six years from now like i don't need
that but
without that it almost feels like some
of these movies are rudderless
like they like they were so dependent on
that that now that they can just be kind
of their own standalone thing i mean a
little bit like they don't necessarily i
totally agree that they don't need to be
uh building the overarching metaplot
with every film but
you have to bring something new to the
character by their fourth movie and i
don't think they had that and i think
you need to bring something
interesting to a villain or at least
work with the villain that you have in
that film to build them up into a
meaningful yeah and i mean i think there
are ideas in this movie that are good or
that could have developed into something
interesting i just think yeah there's so
many of them and we're splitting our
time and we're not really taking any of
them seriously enough to develop it into
a real story it's just jumping from this
to that to this to that and i mean i
think gore's uh christopher bales
there's an interesting nugget of a
character there that's not explored and
i think natalie portman
you know her jane is on an interesting
journey in this but it's we don't really
get delve into it at all she has a
couple of snarky one-liners
and then that's it right uh and and yeah
so i think it's a lack of focus
uh it really really understands that
just leaves you leaves it as just kind
of a skeleton to hang jokes on and when
the jokes aren't funny man it's it's
it's
it's a series of like sketches where
nothing like pays out yeah and it does
feel like we we saw this a little bit in
the the sort of the marketing and when
they were talking about it there were
there were lots of discussions about how
loose the sort of production on some of
these are and how they're shooting
things and then you did this like a not
a fight like a paul fee movie where he
shot four hours and then just picked
like his favorite right and like dropped
it in and figured a lot of it out in
post and i think in this case you can
kind of tell the movie just feels a
little bit slap dash and and a little
bit of a kitchen sink approach people
are being very harsh on that there's one
sort of unfortunate sequence where the
only way to
make the you know get the information to
the characters that they need is uh a
boy's face sort of appears
magically behind them in a room and is
like hey thor
come visit me in space
and
people were making fun of the effect
which doesn't look great but i it's
really it's not even the effect i don't
think that's the problem it's that
you when you write yourself oh it's an
orbeez level uh dialogue where it's like
uh hey thor we need to go in space yeah
do a spiderman i think right that's
that's just that's just also my name is
actually my name is axel now that's just
like i need thor to have this
information and the only way he can get
it is this kid beams it to him from
space so he starts talking just throw
that in there and it it like something
like that really takes you out of the
movie all right enough talking heads
let's watch the trailer
in a cinematic universe that's 14 years
old so no wonder they've entered their
awkward phase comes taika why td sequel
to ragnarok that feels a little how
should i put this
unfocused
nice
thor
love and thunder
ragnarok cranked up the comedy drama and
cars i mean
i'm only making this comparison because
we just finished recording uh nope right
before this but i think that that is uh
there was a moment where i think jordan
peele was producing a lot but as far as
like the stuff he's writing and
directing like he has just stayed yes
working was produced a lot he did the
candyman movie the twilight zone show
but that's yeah he's got like that other
show that's coming out now yeah he's
still tyka is like actively writing
directing and acting oh yeah like 17
things is doing a ton of stuff and he's
just tiger's in that that place too
where he's like developing a lot of
things that then don't necessarily
happen like we even showed like that
akira movie fell through and that time
bandit show i don't know if that's still
active and like oh everything that i
looked up was
timeless it's like it's still go we're
just waiting for his schedule to open up
of course he's doing a million other
things and like i get it because he's
he's another one of those guys just like
jordan peele is getting every meeting
and they'll bring him in for anything at
this point there are two wolves inside
of you guys two directors inside of you
yeah
see what happens when you just keep
cranking in a film with the joke rate of
family guy the plot of fault in our
stars and by the way like the
it's kind of uh indicative of the comedy
to me is that they just went back to the
well of the of the dramatic reenactment
but it's like a different celebrity this
are more celebrities this morning right
like that was such a fun surprise in
thor ragnarok and then it's like this is
the problem with comedy sequels is
you're doing the same jokes over and
over again um yeah it's doing the the
anchorman two news fight again yeah
no you can't tell the same joke but
louder it doesn't make it any fun
sir i i begged it differently
i will try it again all right keep going
look at that time you shroom dead dave
and busters
[Music]
let's find the damn remote so we can
download the distractions
that makes it clear marvel is pushing
their fx artist to the brink only to get
publicly roasted by their millionaire
bosses does that look real
in that particular shot no actually
you've watched thor find love find a new
weapon and find himself now watch him
find excuses to run through the same
character arcs all over again as chris
hemsworth tries to squeeze something new
out of a role he's played for 10 years
and eight films but there's nothing left
for him to give except hang dong and be
done with it and flicker
nice okay you can have a carb now flick
too
thrill at whatever different more
interesting movie christian bale is in
as he brings a menace to gore the god
butcher that comes from spending four
hours in makeup all your co-stars walton
has said in their pj's
i should have put the the interview in
but i watched one with christian bale
where he's like
yeah i was looking at the call sheet and
i was like why is mine four hours
earlier than everybody else i was like
oh i thought this was gonna be like i
thought i was gonna be like an alien
prosthetic creature like they would just
green screen me like korg or something
like that no no no no no no no you gotta
show up buddy you're just gonna be
wrinkly by far the most famous person on
this movie and we are going to paint you
for four hours you're just gonna sit
still pavement like one of your
christian veils
yeah sucks uh but i thought he looked
great and uh and gave a great
performance but it's gone too soon it's
like uh yeah it's it's an interesting
thing because that they've set up he's
basically we don't know his character
because his character appears in one
scene in the beginning and then he's
he's poisoned by this sword sure so it's
really the sword is what's making him
evil and the rest of the movie he's sort
of playing what gore
after he's made crazy by the sword so it
is it's an excuse for bale to just go to
11 the whole time because it's like he's
playing an evil sword basically
uh
oh that's my motivation you're an evil
you're an evil sword that got that found
a body and now you're just like so so on
that level i really enjoyed his
performance because it does feel like
well go for broke like there's nothing
yeah there's no level of realism and i
wanted to see that i think that's in a
movie that purports to be like fun and
you can do anything like
have him wan walk into zeus's hall and
butcher some gods you're gore the god
but have him fight that giant
butcher a few gods would have been good
he's only butchers one god in the in the
whole film and that's when you can get i
would because i would much rather rather
than them having that thing of like oh
well here's like the
god council party orgy i would god city
if we're not gonna see the orgy by the
way like stop telling like just make an
energy but
check out zorgie thank you ryan but so
if it's going to be that then i would
rather if you're going to showcase all
of these wild wacky gods have him go
from different places and like kill
their gods i want to see christian
stab a dumpling yeah he's like literally
in god's ella and it's like i don't care
yeah you don't get a title like god
butcher without but which would be
particularly gruesome if it's a soup
dumpling then it smells everywhere oh
it's everywhere
like a pork dumpling i like can't even
bite into those it just hurts my teeth
they're so good all right keep going eat
a soup dumpling quest to kill the gods
themselves and they'll kill exactly one
of them on camera in self-defense
take that nick offerman
god placing him in the marvel hall of
fame of great actors wasted and
disposable villain rules don't kill them
again villains who are right
normal heroes only fight to preserve the
status quo
go child soldiers go save those elites
with your tiny little eyes
rounding out a fantastic foot of heroes
is valkyrie the king of new asgard she's
sort of an alcoholic that's essential
sort of a viking warrior you pretty much
have to die in battle otherwise you
don't get into valhalla it's my plan
i wish i could join you but i'd probably
die and that won't help these kids back
and definitely the black best friend in
a rom-com about thor having sex with his
weapons it's sleek it's slender it's
powerful it's beautiful
for you i love it for you valkyrie
stormbreaker what are you doing is this
about mjolnir oh you moved on quick
didn't you
got some piece of work
what
we were just talking it must be hard for
you to see your ex-girlfriend and your
yeah
this goes on too long
so
weird it's so weird yeah what a weird
thing and it's that's like a one one
beat joke you do that once and it's like
because it's not in any other thor movie
it's not like they introduced that in
the first one that he's got this like
romantic relationship with his hammer
right yeah but they really hit that hard
over and over again and it like it
doesn't go anywhere yeah also like you
let captain america get all up on that
hammer dude so is that like polyamory
like what are we just passing it around
it's weird it's just like such a weird
like there's that there is this show
where he's in the hot dog outfit and
like natalie port was asleep and it's
like they were hanging out on halloween
and he's having like a late night like
gab session girl talk with the hammer
like she's just so special to me man
it's like we we've never seen any
indication that thor has this kind of
relationship with his hammer yeah
they're not like anthropomorphic weapons
i don't think he's ever spoken to it in
another thor movie and and valkyrie is
going back to that just completely third
wheeled or fourth wheeled between like
thor the the weapons and jane and they
just don't know they don't know what to
do they don't know what to do with her
she changes from scene to scene um and
not in a way where it's like oh she's
complex it's just a way like wait who
they don't know what to do no because
clearly like i think the idea is she uh
is now in this position to be king of
asgard and then like she's like bored of
it because she'd rather be part of the
fight plus also she misses all of her
lesbians and so i feel like that's like
a huge part of the story they're trying
to tell but they don't tell that story
they're too busy making thor like
make out with his weapons yeah there's
no arc of like she feels constrained by
this and she needs to break free and get
back to like she's just there kind of
snark vaguely snarking to the side of
everything else going it's because it's
the marvel formula is part of the deal
is the hero has to like round up their
their posse right you know like their
little crew of their the their people
who are going to help them like like
shang chi's got his you know aquafina
and bringing ben kingsley along for the
ride and it's like that it's so
gratuitous at this point we just accept
that it's gonna happen even if those
people don't even have a really
compelling reason right they're just
there and like yeah like it's the same
with korg where cork's just always
around like he doesn't have an
independent mind of his own he's like
well we off to next door like i'm in
your movie with you you know like it's
just like why are you here like what do
you know and then they realized that
like oh this the the final moment needs
to belong to uh thor and jane so just
have valkyrie stay home
yeah oh my kidney hurts
okay i thought you were are you a god or
i don't know who's are you who is a god
in this what's a god what is it all
right let's keep going we'll we'll get
to that very niche
we good
yeah
i mean i know it's a little weird how's
this still going
come on
in the past then there's korg the urkel
of asgard who's grown from the comic
relief to a main character and the
narrator who steadfastly refuses to shut
up shut up or die turns out the only
part of a cronin that's alive is his
mouth
and jane foster thor's x who stage four
cancer is temporarily cured by his
hammer a subplot that would require a
careful balance of zany fantasy and
relatable pathos or you could just make
a joke out of it every single time jane
it's stage four i have like how many
stages four that we know about ha ha
i thought maybe if science isn't working
maybe viking space magic
something's affecting her body's ability
to fight the cancer i'm sorry thor
ah
there's a joke coming right some [ __ ]
made a fridge without a door can you
believe it
huh
pause
it's impossible to convey in a trailer
the absolute whiplash this movie has of
like wacky cancer wacky cancer wacky
cancer like every time
i think i'm having fun they drop a
cancer on me and then they go back to
jokes there's literally a shot where
thor has just won a battle and like
lifts his axe and there's a joke and
then you pan up beyond the axe and and
natalie portman slides into the frame
getting a cat scan
right in it right in the uh mri machine
yeah right and it's just like certainly
taika ytt recognized this is a weird
trend it's a weird
obviously that's that's that's
unfortunate there was nothing else you
could put in there
peanut butter and tuna fish man i'm
trying to think of like i think it's the
type of humor too because i think that
there are there's plenty of comedy that
uh
addresses cancer or death and stuff like
i mean there are comedy dramas or
comedies about you
yeah exactly like there are ways to do
it but they're not goofy right
they're not just like mugging for the
camera and making making lots of
references and and and quips and stuff
like that it's just a it's a bad mix
it's a bad mix yeah i it also just i
don't know there's something about how
because they've made part of the story
that well at the moment that she touches
the hammer healthy and then the moment
she puts it down and it just invites
like well then the depiction of cancer
becomes very like tropey and unfortunate
where you're creating this like that's
what it looks like to have cancer you
should just like avoid doing that in a
movie i think
yeah like you're in sweatpants and you
have bags under your eyes like
are we doing this it's weird that we're
i know this is from the comics but like
we're
building up jane into the new thor and
killing her off in one movie when she
was completely absent from the last one
it was just like a shot of the back of
her head and end game like it's asking a
lot of us to
care this deeply about jane foster from
thor the dark world yeah yes
i very genuinely believe that they like
brought natalie portman it was like no
like we're going to give you like some
this is your good stuff like some meat
you can chew on you're going to get to
be really funny and you're going to get
to be buffed but then also we're going
to have this really tragic thing it's
like oh this is this is what you can
that would be fine but then it's like we
also have to do a b c d e if you're
gonna do that i think you can do that
but like that's the movie it takes a
movie to tell that story you can't do
that story and then fun detour to god
city with the goats
that's too much you're asking too much
i would have cut gods i hated godzilla i
would have cut god's sake
russell crowe is fun but like we don't
need to go to god's sake you could just
go to
zeus like and ha and kill some of the
other like greek guys yeah you could go
down yeah
yeah maybe some of the moon knight
godzilla we also write what's a god what
anubis that's a moon knight guy yeah but
like go to their different ways
yeah moonlight we did a god meeting uh
and then dr strange too there's
illuminati which is basically a god
meeting like i think they're
overestimating our interest in god's
having me look i think eternals also was
god meetings i think everyone was on
zoom for so many years during like
lockdown that everyone's like
everything's a meeting now this god
meeting could have been a god
yeah
all right keep going
lower your expectations for a
candy-coated tumor held together by a
hundred screaming goat jokes
[Applause]
but hey not every comic book film has to
be so serious
or connect to the larger narrative of
the mcu
or bring a new dimension to favorite
characters
or introduce cool new heroes
or build up a new big villain
or have a central theme
or smoothly shift between tones
or explain what a god even is
or have clearly defined stakes
or make sense in general
or be consistently funny
or look good outside of action scenes
or
start
blonde god van damme
the version we wanted more of a white
christian who hates polytheism tests
your might hey guys it's me cork the
narrator now gonna be hearing a whole
lot more from me throughout the whole
entire movie actually basically every
scene hope you enjoy it it's definitely
what a thor me was supposed to be all
about excited to be part of it probably
stop this at any moment i wanted to but
i'm convinced to get funny enough but
just keep on lingering about and keep on
talking the firstborn child hemsworth
promised to kevin feige
chad eater hired guns the herc with the
mouth thor the dark world and every
streamer at a convention
good to see you in person buddy good to
see you
finding chemo
wait is thanos fun now he tried to
murder half the universe isn't this like
opening up a hitler burger
well there you go
yeah i put mussolini's pizza
and you changed it to hitler burger
another interesting behind the scenes
well there's a because we didn't have a
picture of
i'm not latinos i'm just for the
interest of the fans yeah they can they
can follow how these how the sausage
gets how these things develop yeah uh
muslin burgers sounds funny yeah um
has anyone played mussolini you don't
see a lot of people taking on that role
on film i i don't know
i feel like there's it's one of those
names people know but if you ask them
like to name things il ducey actually
did i don't know most people i think
people mostly just know like the grim
upside down i think they know the like
maybe what he looks like in the training
time quote yeah
chris pratt for mostly
i'm putting it out there obviously
it's me
it's me
okay uh
let's pause to see
italian fans are just turning themselves
and you're right and they're come back
um
we're making fun of whatever
okay some stuff happening on twitch.tv
backslash fandom uh
on thursday 7 a.m um
hey you get up early if you want to
catch the capcom tokyo game show
presentations from tokyo there you go uh
mega man will be there live the actual
mega man mega man
chris patterson
yeah um also on thursday at 3 p.m uh
pacific the fandom game club continues
with call of the sea chapters three and
four
uh hear that call and sometimes the sea
calls and you gotta get answers yeah uh
uh the sea was angry
like an old man trying to send back soup
in a deli and then friday we'll be
streaming uh 8 a.m there's a street
fighter event i don't know if that's
part of capcom's
thing okay so yeah get your diago on do
the do the counters um and then do uh 11
a.m uh check back in on the twitch for
rings of power watch along um whatever
episode's out now uh we're watching it
here live for uh and now we have some
outtakes i think let's see oh and can
you tell them andrew wait for us next
week i'm sorry okay we're doing um
indoors
wednesday
hi
cherry coke what can i say um and or
starts next week if you didn't hear ryan
we're well yeah we'll be doing whether
thursdays
thursdays oh and or wednesdays
thursdays a lot of that's a lot of
disney plus um
all right well uh let's check out the
outtakes from thor
starring
kimbo slice project northmen
v for viking gaines foster
foul killer
by frosty
taika the rock ytd
how i killed your father
den of thieves
master and fellaini only that was gerard
butler he's here he's there he's
everywhere roy canned roy canned
mighty pythons in the holy mail
guns and bruises
get him to the greeks
what do you think jane's final
catchphrase choice was cause i got a
suggestion
[Music]
yeah that was a running thing that
didn't really pay off of like what's my
catchphrase what's uh yeah no one well
then an mcu has a catchphrase and they
didn't come up with a good one by the
end eat my hammer is that where she
lands i think she whispers one and then
yeah no she does three she's like first
you could call me dr jade foster at
second it's this and then third eat my
hammer and it's like none of those are
good
if you don't have a good one don't do
the bit
all right uh
let's see um adam halpert says i died
laughing with this movie well that's
great i like this i'm sorry that he's
dead yeah uh i don't get how marvel fans
are so angry when the drama big world
stakes and deaths are pointless after
end game well again like it's humor
subjective and if you're not laughing
this is a comedy
first and foremost this is a comedy i
think more so than most marvel movies
and it wasn't particularly funny and
he's doing that he's doing that thing
that that rhetorical sleight of hand a
lot of people do where it people who
didn't like it are angry like
some people just didn't like it i'm not
angry i'm disappointed yeah they may not
be furious it's like people like it
people didn't like it people are
entitled to their opinion not everybody
who disagrees with you is an infuriated
monster
whatever yeah i liked it
ryan liked it ryan liked it but you know
but for yeah yeah if it just
stop it if a joke uh if a joke doesn't
work for me then uh then it winds up
being irritating that's all it is i'm
kidding
and then the movie's over and i never
think of it again i actually don't think
i hated it as much as as you did i i it
was more just like
within 20 minutes of a marvel movie i
can tell if it's just doing the thing
that the marvel movies do that kind of
is on my nerves at this point or if it's
doing something of its own that i'm
interested in and this one it kind of
set in after like oh okay i get what
this one is it's not it's not sort of my
favorite chongqi i also had that feeling
about but i did like the action that way
i like that i like the the sort of the
wusha style martial arts stuff in that
better than anything in this but yeah um
yeah so here's uh here's some uh related
questions benzy10 and zack morris are
both writing basically about the next
generation of uh that's showing up in
these movies lots of story lines with
kids these days oh yeah all the heroes
are getting stuck with kids uh and ben's
in tennessee will thor's kid love
actually stick around or mysteriously
disappear in the future
um
i think that they're obviously trying to
build up a younger adventure
yeah because uh thor is really one of
the last ogs still around like ruffalo i
mean he spread his involvement out for
so long he's barely had his own thing
yes um but i really thought that this
could have and maybe should have been
chris hemsworth send off but instead it
kind of seemed like the start of a whole
new adventure with him and him in love
yeah well and people loved
um but that kind of like lone wolf and
cub thing is like a thing that people
have been exploring in these well in you
know pop culture forever but
specifically in comic book movies a lot
yeah and and and mandalorian for disney
yes baby baby everything give me a baby
everything put a baby in it but yeah i
mean we are obviously i think i think
there is a ip
franchise building aspect to this
because we've got ant-man's got a
daughter that's going to be in quantum
mania is a featured player we got uh
there's a new hawkeye who's yeah kate
bishop lawrence pugh is a younger sister
well we know she's going to thunderbolts
but i feel like i feel like there's
enough other young people being
introduced now that we're definitely
going to right we're going to get
younger
some kind of young avengers teen
avengers team there must be even if it's
just in the brainstorming
area right now i think inevitably tom
holland is going to have to play a
teenager well if he was 30.
start stretching out 45 year old tom
holland shaving
this is happy dog
uh
he's just doing money he's just doing
marty mccly especially in in infinity
war radar city update channel i think
we're getting some shade but then marvel
does eternals and it's ew why are you
trying something different hey two
things can be bad at the same time
look at that
eternals
uh that's true that's true look eternals
was different and i thought um
a miss in most respects for me for me
and i thought that thor
wasn't doing anything differently he was
just doing it worse it was just not
doing it as well as they used to that's
all
um uh atlanta yeah it's not a binary
it's not like if movie did x if did y
would be good like that's not how any
movie look if you show me anymore you
show me any more of thor four i'm going
to destroy the set
that's what's
raider city happening continue to say
what would you be the god of for example
the god of charcuterie boards that's a
good god yeah
well that it's interesting because thor
thor for like
they introduced the god of dumplings
which you would think traditionally
would be a humanoid making and eating
dumplings and instead it's a it's a
dumpling it's a living dumpling so
dumplings are sentient in worship right
but that's what i'm saying like if
you're the god of charcuterie boards are
you a piece of charcuterie or are you
the whole person who enjoys like pizza
hut like yeah
because that doesn't sound pleasant but
if it was just a a being that produces
and enjoys a lot of charcuterie boards
oh man just like a bunch of meat and
cheese and nuts and jams just like
coming together and making a face that
sounds gross i don't want to be sitting
well uh i will be the god of um
eating dinner too early because you have
a three-year-old and then it's like 9 30
10 p.m and you're hungry again and you
eat an entire bag of peanut butter
pretzels from trader joe's right before
you go to sleep i think that's just the
god of eating disorders
it's not a disorder i'm just it's just
you eat a whole bag of something right
right before you go to bed that's my
move
these days
um i'm obviously the god of wig spotting
wig spotting yep yeah that's i mean
that's that's what i'm the god of yeah
god of contents
make that sweet content ryan
uh let's see um
some good stuff here mattanvensky this
film was the most expensive thing in
phase four how much out of the 250
million dollars was spent on threesomes
and how little on vfx i think they spend
a lot on vfx but like they probably had
to spend a lot to make it a lot of it
very quickly well this is the it's
important to clarify like you'll hear us
and a lot of other people dumping on the
effects in these movies sometimes it's
never like the people who made the
effects didn't do a good job they're
great and they're they're talented and
they're they'd be doing what they're
doing for any
movie or project or whatever it's always
it's about the budget it's about the
time it's about all the constraints and
it's about how much gets changed at the
last minute like we're saying when we
say they're kind of creating these
movies in post that's really what we
mean it's up to the effects artist to be
like okay take this out put this in
change that there was that shot in in
spider-man of uh daredevil grabbing the
brick that got thrown through the window
and a lot of people that there's some
aspects of it didn't look quite right
because it wasn't originally a brick it
was a different object and the vfx
artist had to go in at the very last
second and change it into a brick and
those are those things are happening in
every scene of this all the time so it's
not about the the
individual artists making the vfx it's
about it's about the rush and the crunch
the constraints
that they're putting on the whole
project that makes the vxx come out
looking a little they're really only so
many companies that can do this quality
of work this level of work and marvel is
employing 90 of them and then the rest
of the film industry is employing the
other 10 and there's just not enough
there's enough time and then they're
coming in at the last minute after
they've animated the scenes they
actually we take kirk tessa thompson's
not in this scene anymore get rid of her
and put natalie portman in her place
that's a lot of work and also remember
that a lot of because of the way that
like shutdown happened and because of
like uh lockdown and quarantine a lot of
folks are like doing this stuff from the
rigs in their houses and that takes
forever to be able to like take time to
to
render um take time to actually transfer
i know people who were editors on tv
shows what you used to be able to go in
and do and then just have now you are
doing from home which requires like a
whole other different thing so it's like
remember some things have also changed
because of lockdown yep um and just a a
movie like thor which is two and a half
hours long and or no two hours
but i think every scene is an effect
shot oh yeah they're constantly and i
mean they're doing that thing they're
put the four of them are walking in a
room in burbank and then they're putting
god city behind them yeah um gutsy is a
strip club in burbank really
uh there's a there's a jim henson tv
special called dog city and the the
and the the theme is dog city everybody
wants to go and i keep every i can't
think about god city i think about it
that leads us into next week's honest
trailer which also has a song about a
dog
it's gonna
like a hounded
we'll see you next week thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you